[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hello all right let me
let me explain what's going on yes I'm
I'm late for some reason Zoom decides it
doesn't want to work correctly so we are
going to Discord
uh almost done guys
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's a problem
can you guys hear me
are you guys able to hear me
man I'm stressing today
oh my God no dirt dirt had some stuff to
do with his mom
uh he had some family stuff uh so he
won't be here today
attic from 2007. how does the the
quality of the stream look guys
we got a five dollars trap from Hit F go
blunted Xbox eating good games and new
hardware like the series s Third Edition
controllers x-lab also uh one of the
alien species from Starfield
I think that's a a thing for
for Dart
it's not that it's windowed guys it's
just like
like I almost just canceled the show
when the uh when my stuff wasn't working
correctly I ain't gonna lie to you
it it just it's stressing me out man
it's stressing me out
man people I don't understand how
difficult it is to get a show going they
think it's just like it's hit a button
you go live and you just start talking
but it's like all the
the ins and outs the issues all of the
various programs that are supposed to
work correctly and then you turn them on
and they just like completely crap out
that's just like almost like it doesn't
matter how much you
how much prep you do
it just doesn't matter it's just like
because the moment you go live it's just
oh that stuff goes out the window yeah
and you know I appreciate everyone
coming through it's just it's been a
hectic day I apologize uh one of the
reasons
uh one of the reasons that I'm on
streamlines because I was just going to
put it on stream yard but Cog wants to
try out this new like formula stuff uh I
don't know if it's working I don't know
if the stream looks sharper than normal
I don't know is your view flipped
uh
I'm unaware if it's flipped or not
I hope we're here to you you talk I I
hear you there man I hear you that
what's going on you guys
Lord out if you're getting me out of
here coming at you for another attic
show we talk about the past present
future gaming unfortunately dirt is
unavailable he he had some stuff he had
to do
I don't know what's going on I I had
some family stuff man uh but I wanna I
got slow-mo back slap uh you know he
he's a prominent person in the community
and uh we've had a lot of interesting
conversations throughout the years
so what's up man yeah so appreciate you
you coming through man I appreciate you
coming through
hey no problem bro you know I I I uh the
the best symbol went up and I said well
you know why not I ain't got I ain't
doing much else but just playing video
games trying to juggle a job and kids
and family I'm like no I might juggle
something else you can do another
podcast today let's do it yeah it's it's
a little crazy man especially I was just
gonna cancel today when uh dirt wasn't
able to make it but like with all the
stuff that's going on today I just felt
like
there's just too much to cancel like
right it's it's really hard to not like
go live and talk about this stuff man
there's just so much going on and like
every I feel like every hour there's
like a new news thing that on a normal
week this would be like one of the
biggest things you talk about but it's
like enough it's just you know one of
like a dozen other things that get
released you know over the past like 48
Hours like did you hear about Crystal
Dynamics
they laid off some people I'm kind of
getting like mixed reporting like if
someone told me it was like half the
staff someone told me it was just the pr
yeah yeah they they actually came out
with the statement I guess and I'm glad
they did to clear things up so that
people weren't going around you know
running with like the entire Studio has
been laid off kind of stuff but
apparently it was 10 people
one guy was an I.T guy a shout out to
him uh you know us it people got sick
together you know and then the other
nine were brand marketing people so
brand marketing people yeah it's just
like I think when it comes to me man
it's just like this this whole thing was
just crazy like we we go from one leaked
rumors to another leap rumors it's just
you know I I got some stuff
but first off chat what what leaks do
you guys want to talk about I kind of I
want to talk about the games leaks
because I think that's uh extremely
important
pretty much all of bethesda's stuff was
leaked I think uh
here's the thing
bleaks aren't rumors you are true
but there was so much information given
yesterday
the odds of India being fake is very low
but we still have to consider it as a
rumor because you know Phil might have
came out and kind of like agreed that
all that was real
but at the end of the day like we we got
to
acknowledge that some of these this some
of these could definitely change oh yeah
absolutely and I mean he even said so
that's a lot of it's old information and
won't necessarily be things that will
come to pass and we don't know what is
and isn't going to come to pass but
that's that's definitely true like you
gotta acknowledge that these were the
plans that they are currently going to
go forward with or we're going to go
forward with but some of them have
changed and that you know at the same
time I think kinda they they are
justifiably pissed about the mistake
that whoever on their side made because
they've exposed
a lot of game planning you know for like
long-term future that their competition
is going to look at and potentially try
to make calendar moves towards and it's
one of those things where you know I I
don't know how you feel Slovak because I
tell you how I feel I feel like
did PlayStation know everything on this
no but I'm willing to bet you they knew
the majority
you know uh yeah I can see that maybe
like for example you know the one slide
where they're talking about the next
Xbox right in 2028 like I'm pretty sure
like a good number of that stuff
PlayStation new wanting to go with navi5
okay yeah like think you think you you
use AMD like they use AMD so if you look
at the way the generations go yeah that
would make sense but then when they were
talking about potential arm like going
that going Navi or arm I don't know if
PlayStation was was aware of little
things like that or a custom Apu that
could do wasn't just you know off the
off the the uh the rack kind of
architecture from AMD that's a little
different and I think that they you know
if nothing none of this stuff came out
and they went that route they could have
taken PlayStation by surprise with that
but unfortunately
no surprises now yeah so yeah okay so
let's talk about the the logistics of
things okay games
if we get leaks that Oblivion is being
is being remade and Fallout 3 is being
remade the only one I didn't never heard
a rumor about was was Dishonored
that's the only one that kind of make me
think okay
yeah maybe maybe no idea they were wrong
maybe they head down a little bit too
good uh why do you talk I'm going to
get rid of this real quick
you know also there was something that I
saw so remember this is a particular
part I'm going to find because I
actually have it up and there was a
particular when they were talking about
the games
there is uh so Indiana Jones is on the
list right and we know that's a licensed
game with lucasfilm but then there was
this other game that was like it said
license game and they were both on the
list at the same time so it's like
clearly that's not Indiana Jones that's
another license game that Bethesda is
working on so I I saw that was like oh
wow so what else does Bethesda have a
license for yeah that's a you know we're
going to get into that definitely
because I think that's people they I
felt like a lot of people were looking
at stuff that I wouldn't say wasn't
important but it was just duh like
people sitting there going all about a
conversation that Phil had with um
with people about buying Nintendo it's
like dude he's literally said on
multiple different occasions that he
would love to own Nintendo like it's
just like first off who wouldn't love to
own Nintendo like Microsoft and Nintendo
joining together you could argue would
be like a very Unstoppable Force like
it's like who who wouldn't want that
like PlayStation wanted it
because they tried so it's just like I
feel like people you know obviously I
get it you know we
we got a lot of stuff going on at the
same time so I could understand why
people are like that where they want
what's going on
but it's a bit I do think it's a bit
exaggerated and it's a bit exaggerated
because of how people are with their
their camps you know they're you know I
gotta fight for this side to let me
argue every single point that I could
probably conceivably come up with for a
particular side but let's keep it a buck
as if Jim Ryan was in Phil Spencer's
position do you think Jim Ryan would
hesitate to acquire a Nintendo if you
could
no
like what it's about is what do you have
in your War chest what do you what
assets what weapons do you have have at
your disposal and what Phil has at his
disposal is Microsoft's checkbook
so when it comes to how he's going to
engage his competition or potential
competition or potential allies
yeah there's when you have a completely
separate platform that's very unique and
makes the makes the kind of money that
they make so I'm gonna be looking at
trying to do things all right so there
has been more stuff to get leaked I
don't know if people have seen this it's
being reported on right now uh so I
don't know if it's new or something but
they have the budgets
on you know they have the budgets the
the active users everything when it
comes to what is being so uh like they
have the total revenue like they have
the quarterly stuff for last like the
exact numbers have you guys seen that
I've seen no I haven't seen that I have
not seen that part all right so let's do
a little show and tell
uh because uh this is this is kind of a
tense
all right so as you guys could see
uh you know I brought this up now uh so
this is what I'm seeing obviously I
don't know uh if this has been there
but let's talk about this real quick um
look at this the stream uh slow mo
because here in a second I'm gonna be
able to see it yeah I see it all right
so let's talk about this a little bit
total revenue
yeah 13 uh 13 billion so they had a they
had a plus nine percent of going last
time so what's interesting is they made
13 billion but their budget was 17. uh
so they actually didn't
I'm kind of curious is that mean like
there so they made 13 billion did they
spend 17
no I think that I think or is that their
projections that they thought they were
going to get I think that's how much
money how much money they were allocated
out of Microsoft total revenue they were
allocated 17.7 billion for
2022 or the fiscal year 2022 and what
they actually uh uh uh actually earned
was like 13. so but then you kind of
look at like
uh
actually well well yeah I mean when it
comes to Xbox one free active users what
do you mean by budget of that yeah
that's 117 and then you got 112. yeah I
do
so okay okay yeah I guess I guess maybe
I'm looking at this wrong so okay so
their budget was seven like okay so
their budget all of 2022. so this is
just the third quarter they made 13
billion uh the the third quarter uh the
first quarter well one out of three I
don't know if that means uh exactly I
don't know how to read these things uh I
think their budget for everything
was 17 billion because if you look here
2.2
14.4 35 uh 35 million 117 million uh so
I I don't I don't know if that means
they got that or that okay who cares
we're go we're going on to important
[__] apparently in quarter we're the
time period of this isn't this like from
2020 like fall look to 2022 so maybe
what they have what they showed right
there with the the q1 the three is where
they actually were at
and the on the right side is what they
anticipated they would be getting or
anticipated they'd be doing by the end
of the entire fiscal year but they they
haven't of course that hasn't happened
yet as of that time period when they
sent that out so
so apparently Xbox game pass subscribers
at this point was 24 million
uh so you know it's kind of and he
projected 35 hmm
yeah yeah so I think that's what it is
like they're definitely did not miss
their quotas in some of these
you know Xbox so the this is just the
gaming so this is more than just Xbox
this is like their whole gaming division
but I would say Xbox makes up a large
quantity of this
um
they they're having decent numbers like
what's crazy is they they projected 35
but it's just like with what redfall
right and that was that was uh yeah
exactly those projections were made when
before rifle and Starfield got delayed
any people in the chat I know aren't
crazy you could tell me and I'll I know
and I add you to the call on Discord
it's fine
um I think this is interesting it's
interesting I I wouldn't like go crazy
with it but I think it's interesting I
think at the end of the day man it just
depends on you know what's doing what I
think that's the important part as long
as there's growth that's all that
matters
yeah game share says again I think
that's pretty much where I was getting
at how I uh eventually got to
understanding it a game share in the
chassis and corporate world budget is
another word for goal or hopeful
achievement so like that when you look
at it that that makes a lot of sense
that they were anticipating hopefully
being at 35 million game Pratt Game Pass
subscribers by the end of the fiscal
year and where they got was was uh well
at that time period when they sent that
out was 24. so that makes sense
okay it's his but
do you honestly realistically think that
they expected growth from redfall like
look red fall to me was a very
underwhelming experience and I don't
think it was screaming go out and get
Game Pass I just don't
I honestly feel like they had no idea
what rifle was until very very late in
the and by then it was just too late
development yeah by then they had
already did a expensive CG five minute
trailer did the whole one more thing at
at their XBox showcase and there's no at
that point you're too committed to like
really give it the significant delay it
needed to be good or to just cancel it
because it probably never would be and
they were just too committed at that
point so I think that I think for them
they may have learned a lesson there
that
if we're going to
acquire a publisher a studio and we're
going to look at their portfolio of
games and just say just like check marks
for everything sure go forward before we
do that let's actually look at these
games and see if this is something that
we actually want if this screams
anything it screams you need to double
check everything like don't don't don't
just assume never assume because uh you
know you can argue that assuming made
them look like an ass this particular
time because oh absolutely
oh man
um did you did you see uh the the I I've
been talking to some people that find
this super fascinating but the slides
where they talk about where Xbox was as
far as Hardware
and accessories at launch to today to
um XBox gaming Beyond did you know this
in Xbox gaming Beyond they have
they have what looks like a handheld and
we don't know whether that's a handheld
they're going to be creating or not or
whether it's just they feel like the Rog
Ally fulfills that role because some of
the stuff in there like smart TVs
clearly they ain't making a smart TV
right but there's also stuff that we
definitely know they are making
themselves because it's down there with
headsets and controllers and it's like
mobile controller is kind of like the
the backbone that you would put on your
your iPhone there's a one-handed
controller which I have no idea how that
would work but uh the new controller
that everyone's talking about and also
mouse and keyboard I just found a like
like a lot of the little things like
this fascinating because even though
there aren't some big like dedicated
slide to that stuff you know this
information is at some point will come
some of this stuff will come to to pass
and actually be released you know
and what's funny is that I'm I'm on here
right now I'm looking
down I think it would be the top because
I want to bring up some of these plans
like people people don't pay attention I
will say that like I feel like I'm
sitting here reading people saying like
Phil Spencer lied and it's just like
this if you would actually pay attention
you would know that like these these
things this is not a Next Generation
console like this is this is like a
every generation we get like uh like
slim versions and that's what this is
it's interesting that they're taking
this concept and they're not
they're not making it cheaper like this
thing costs just the amounts uh you know
rumored it costs just the amount that it
costs now so let me blow it up so we can
you know really read through here
all right so it's the most powerful Xbox
ever no notice they use like unique
language like Xbox because uh they
they're not trying to go towards like
console they kind of abandoned the
console thing a while back
uh so you know the Brooklyn will deliver
4K 9th gen console gaming with more
internal storage because I think it's
got two terabytes faster Wi-Fi reduced
power and more immersive controller and
a beautiful redesign that elevates the
All Digital experience of the Xbox
ecosystem uh so when you when you look
at something like this like this
this thing here there's nothing wrong
with it but I don't get why they made it
look like this like yes I was about to
say that I hate the way it looks the
design I I it looks like a log
it looks like a big black like like I
can it almost feels like if you just
laid it on his side and just pushed it
would just like roll across your your
floor
it just I I I don't like the the way
that this looked I like the the way the
design of the Xbox series
x i I liked it uh that very it was uh it
has a uh an aesthetic that's very like
uniform I like I like that this though
this this
long cylinder looking thing so shout out
the pixel bit the chass hit the x-log
it's like it's gonna get nicknames like
that if they if that ends up being the
the final design that we see next year
like yeah it's it's people going to call
it all kinds of funny stuff like that
you know you got that x-log you know
it's like in that air clock it's like
how are you gonna give it's like the the
production team and the manufacturing
team and the hardware team it's like
they don't pay attention to like Twitter
at all it's like
young people are going to make like
trash can jokes out of this thing oh
yeah like this thing literally looks
like a Bluetooth speaker
like this thing dead ass this looks like
a Bluetooth speaker like one of those
big fancy Bluetooth speakers like it
looks like one of those like and if you
look at the top it looks like that's
where the speaker is like it it just
doesn't matter
in the grand scheme when things smell
uh but it is funny
that they choose to do stuff that I feel
can be used against them on the Internet
because people sit there and say the
internet's not a real place it's not but
the internet can in a lot of cases
decide whether or not you're successful
or not
and you look look at some of the most
iconic things that's happened that the
internet stopped you I don't think
people realize how strong and powerful
the internet is
the the internet has made multi trillion
with a t
multi-trillion dollar companies been
their knee
when it comes to policies like just
think about that yeah the internet it
can supersede reality because because
what really matters isn't that hey look
we we had this well thought out plan we
had all these features we we had all of
these great ideas
but if it's not branded well if it's not
marketed well if it's not explained to
the consumer well then consumer them
they don't give a damn
well if they think or if there's a
narrative that is plausible and makes
sense to them that all that stuff is
irrelevant and maybe the the the the
certain negatives of your your product
are more prominent and more important
that's all that matters
and yeah people just they don't realize
man you know does this matter in the
grand scheme when things no but it's
just like you know one would think they
had learned after the Xbox One got like
mean to death for being a VCR
like but I guess maybe aesthetically
this does look like a VCR I guess
aesthetically like the Brooklyn does
look like something that would be in
your entertainment center
it just I get I guess I mean but also it
could look like something I will put in
my hallway as a vase you know for people
the the wall pass and go oh you know as
they as they walk in my house you know
it's it also looks like that too it
looks like like furniture or something
man maybe that's the idea that it's it
it doesn't
uh you can put it in your house as a
casual hey here we go as a Casual Gamer
that may not be as as confident in your
your in in being vocal about your gaming
as a hardcore gamer would you have this
this vase looking Xbox in your your
house by your TV and people don't even
realize it's an Xbox it just looks like
you know something something that you
you have in your house that looks looks
pretty cool and that's it and maybe
that's the point I don't know but I I
could definitely see
where maybe some of the ideas may have
came from for why it looks the way it
looks outside of just
your the the actual like Engineers
making sure that it works that it's
cooling the the the
components correctly
in that it's not causing a problem where
you end up having a bunch of recalls due
to a improperly created device closed
device you know
yeah so uh I did and you guys did see I
did break I have the
the the Bethesda Elite games which is
insane the amount of games that got
leaked by Bethesda we'll get to that
here in a minute I want to talk about
the series s uh it's clearly you know
it's getting a reiteration as well
I I don't remember what the code name
was called I don't really care to be
honest with you
um
part of me yes or no it's supposed to be
one terabyte and improved Wi-Fi stuff
like that right yeah part of me knew
this was happening but at the same time
slow-mo I'm just like
I don't know what this thing gonna like
run like on these games at the end of
the generation
hmm
yeah I
I feel like it's going to be an issue
like I I truly do look is it gonna be
like a huge issue probably not because
by the time it's like really
preventing games running really well I I
would say it won't be too long before
the generation's over
they're just going to swap it out but
like with the series that's and they're
clearly going to support it they got to
they got a lot of people using the
series s do you think that they should
take this approach Next Generation
Next Generation I think they will
probably just go with one skew next
Generation I think one I don't think
they're gonna go with the two skew
approach anymore but they also will be
for a while into next Generation still
supporting this current generation as
well so
it will be similar to where there will
be a cut-off point but you're still
going to get games coming out for these
devices past 2028 first party games that
is uh but and probably some big third
party ones too you know like you're mad
and your FIFA's your 2ks and the games
that that make a lot on the annual basis
but I I think that
some of the misgivings they have because
I I thought I saw something in there
where they were talking about
um I guess like the Developers
I you know I don't want to speak out to
her but I thought I saw something in
there about what they came to the series
accident about developer or maybe like
like misgivings or something with it but
really they're they are attached to the
hip with this device if you think about
it
uh the initial at the time when this
when this information was put together
it was the split was 75
owners of the series s compared to 25 of
the series X Matt Matt piscatella of MPD
came out today and said that since then
because supply has increased for the
series X that is now more closer to 50
50. not necessarily it being 50 50 but
the series s is is not as as big of a
gap from the series X as it once was but
it's still so many people that
you got to make sure that you have
content parity across the board because
so many of the people who are going to
be playing these games on Xbox quote
unquote are going to be playing it on
the series that's the isn't as powerful
as the series X and so that's something
that you you got to take into account
going to next Generation you got to make
sure that like these aren't issues
anymore like you're gonna need to have
just one skew and if you're gonna and if
you're gonna make it certain choices
just make it like well on one skew it's
the same exact you know model that said
the same exact power and everything
everything but maybe this is all digital
or this is all Cloud because it seems
like they're going away from from
physical period right
this is all cloud and this one is is
like a hybrid or something you know like
they they gotta find a way to to make
sure that power wise the differential
isn't so much for developers that are
developing on it
yeah I think
when it comes to stuff like this
I do think that the series s
would normally hold back the industry
but
when PlayStation makes exclusive
PlayStation games they're not being made
on the series s so it's not holding them
back when third party is developing
games for the most part they're always
developing for either the switch or low
denominators of you know PC Hardware so
that can't hold it back as much you know
if XBox was making exclusive series X
Games I would say would but they're not
because they still have to make PC games
as well and you have to account for you
know weaker Hardware that's in PC
because people don't realize how hard it
is to make like PC games
like when you optimize PC games it's
it's a nightmare and I've been told by
multiple devs so that's why with this
particular thing I don't think it really
holds anything back because there's
always something else that they have to
revolve around as well and Des told me
that you know they spent a lot of time
you know optimizing these console ports
that is holding them back but that's
just time that's not like equivalent to
power or you know CPU usage or anything
like that it's mainly about time you
know the more
excuse you own like people sit there and
say at it but I thought you said it
didn't take uh you know multiple ports
doesn't matter
it definitely matters to smaller teams
yeah if you don't have the resources to
do it all at once yeah you're going to
have to prioritize what's more important
and then work on that first and you
can't then slowly go down the pipeline
or what to be the least important excuse
that you have to optimize for and you
can't tell me companies like EA or
Ubisoft they got no excuse for not every
platform
uh they they probably have support
Studios that just do that
but but you know also when it comes to
PC
the the difference there with PC is that
at any point in time you can just like
every individual game that comes out on
PC has its own minimum requirements on
recommended and then like Ultra spec you
know like everyone waits for the the
spec sheet to come out to see what what
what what work didn't look like today
just just released
no uh Mirage I don't think that's out
yet no I'm talking about the the specs
for it oh I didn't see that but I would
like to check that out I did see
cyberpunk Phantom Liberty spec sheet
come out since you think I think I can
run it fine
uh with the new the new the new pc you
guys oh yeah you'll be fine you'll be
fine if you look look at the spec sheet
you'll you'll be able to play it
um you'll be able to play it 4K 60 with
no with no race racing
um and AMD race racist ain't that great
so they're like but if you turned on
race racing 1840p to be honest yeah 40
40 feet like 1080p at Max race racing
path tracing you could probably run it
like that it looks amazing like from the
stuff I'm seeing today looks amazing
although uh I cdpr did that whole thing
where they only wanted b-roll
pre-recorded footage they provided shown
for any of the reviews which I can't
stand you know what's funny I I did your
boy did hit them up man they they kind
of like they they kind of did me dirty
they're like nah go to terminal I get it
I do but it's like at the same time like
I I it's hard not to be a little bitter
because it's like dude who are you
to hold anything back from anyone at
this point oh yeah because their
reputation of what they did before yeah
it's like
part of me just like
who do you think you're are like you you
think you naughty dog
I get it you know they're doing what's
best for them and you know what's funny
like
people that Captivate and they grow off
of console war off of click like true
clickbait uh stuff off of like political
stuff they got the views because they do
the stuff required to get those massive
views and the industry they don't care
about uh you know they don't care about
morals they don't care about you know
now political stuff they will go left or
right depending on that they will cut
you off for stuff like that and I think
a lot of that is because they're too
scared to get uh they get canceled but
it's just like you know yes the passion
for the games I feel is like the last
thing the industry cares about oh yeah
one one thousand percent look you know
my little little tiny Channel and I've
I've always just cared more about just
the the gaming side of things I don't
really care about uh camps and and and
and console Wars and and and and and
Kyle told what Publishers may want or
want me to say even when I've done like
reviews that I've got review codes and
and I've I've just been you know as
blunt as possible by a particular game
I I don't really care about how the
chips may fall and what they may not
like about what was said but on the on
the ends the inside of things that it's
absolutely not uh something that they
care for so when you ask for a review
code and they know that you may be you
may not toe the line that everyone else
would be told and like uh yeah yeah go
the terminals man yeah we might get you
a code through there eventually Mike
I got a code for Saints Row a full month
after it came out I'm like what what am
I supposed to do with this what is that
like I had to laugh it was pretty funny
people don't realize how hard it is to
grow in the industry without the
industry's help
yeah and it does feel like
the industry's so cliquish
and it's like oh do you rock with this
person or that person if you don't
that's fine we'll get to you when we get
to you one of the things I don't like
about the review system and I talked
about it like pretty extensively when I
interviewed Travis I don't like how
things are done when it comes to like
review access it's like I IOP and myself
like fought so much just to get like
access to reviews and stuff because
that's all okay I care about the games
uh you know I care about the games and
the stuff that makes the games and stuff
that's interesting but in the core I
care about the games
so we fought all this time to get this
this early access you know to to get
these gains before they come out and you
know to be able to to cover them for the
the IOP community and the addict show
Community and then we found out when we
got there
not only do you gotta to fight to get
into the early uh to that to that club
that get these things
then you gotta fight to get up to
certain
you know stairs that's in that club
so it's like now I gotta fight took
years to get to this point on top of
that now I gotta fight to get to a
higher tier in this in this club
and
it's something that I still will never
understand you know if people sit there
and they say oh entitled oh I get it I
get it you know but when you put your
your your sweat tears all this time do
this coverage for all these years
and then you get in like you know I
remember I there was one time
I wanted to review State of Decay too
and I remember making a public statement
I don't know if you remember slow mo it
might have been before like you entered
the community
yeah and I remember having all this
support people a couple people from
Undead lives followed me they didn't
give me no code
and it's just like
damn the passion
you know but if I if I wanted it and I
made it my life's goal to talk negative
about a platform over and over again or
to you know find everything that can can
generate some form of emotion regardless
if it's positive or negative and just
talk about that 24 7 if if I don't put
my face on every thumbnail making crazy
thought uh looks like those are the
people that get the opportunities like
that because they got the viewership
because they've used and that's all that
matters yeah that's all that matters and
yeah and people look and you guys get
great viewership your live viewership on
Sundays for foreign for the podcast it's
it's like a lot of bigger channels
if they went live they wouldn't get that
of course you know the audience mix is
different for every channel but like
they wouldn't get that many people as
many lives just like for your subscriber
number account which is very good yet
you just still get that much is is is is
astronomical that said like
there are channels out here that I see
where they got like 200k subscribers and
they only talk about certain kinds of
games and I know those those concert
creators get every single game that
comes out thrown at them games they
don't even want
games they don't care about and they
never going to play and they just get
the game hey you know yeah we just
dropped this because they're really
hoping that that 200k like like like
30 to 50 cave viewer per per video chain
that would just decides to cover the
game for once you know yeah so let me
get these super chats real quick uh Kiel
Walker he did a member chat time for
another dirt with the gaming show uh
darts I hear apologize for that final
super trap from Alvin because I got the
one above that
Crystal laying off brand marketing
sounds like they're trimming people they
don't need when Xbox gets there I
actually
I think there's some Realm of truth that
might be there you know it do they need
a marketing team if Microsoft picks them
up I don't know how close they are to
you know regardless if they win or not
getting this this ABK deal
it's like I wouldn't be surprised if
they do buy Crystal Dynamics like I
would not be because if you notice like
you told me the majority of like the
people making the games it's still
intact
yeah yeah they only got rid of the
people that Microsoft would have got rid
of anyway like yeah they don't they
don't need their marketing or their ITV
you know they're good they're good on
that front I I buy at my my only
reservation at this point in time is the
fact that
when so embracer is in such a bad
position and they are trying to cut
Corners everywhere they can due to their
financial issues yet at the same time
it's like well Microsoft isn't in the
best position to acquire anyone right
now
someone coming up then question what you
gonna do with that what what right right
if they try to acquire like a tiny 50
team development Studio that has only
made like like game unity games and
they're an indie developer I I would see
I could see Lena Khan scrutinizing that
too it's just like they everything
they're doing right now is under
scrutiny so much so that once this the
ABK deal does close I kind of feel as if
they may need to have a cooling off
period of like at least six months
before they actually really jump in that
pool again to acquire more people you
know so I I do think that they will buy
something else
people talk oh Warner Brothers
Ubisoft EA Nintendo I think once this
ABK deal is done I truly do believe that
they're done buying big companies like
that uh because this if they get ABK
they're like damn that was close like
this is like if they don't get ABK you
think they're gonna risk more money to
buy them again to buy something else
like them again you know I'm not saying
that they wouldn't buy a company but I I
think they're going to stick to I would
say the most they would spend after this
is like nine billion dollars on anything
like I don't think they'll go above nine
uh you know uh Warner Brothers I think
they would buy Warner Brothers because I
don't think Warner Brothers is as
expensive as people think you know uh
Phil Spencer says in the email that the
problem with one of us they would get
none of the IPS
yeah so and that's that's problematic
and that that's where you get the
majority of a price point you know when
they bought Bethesda people say well
they they are outbid they overpaid for
Bethesda did they they got the Elder
Scrolls franchise The Fallout franchise
the Doom franchise uh they they got all
of these iconic franchises the Starfield
franchise obviously that was probably on
the lower scale because it hasn't been
out there but they they got Quake
franchise it it's just like and then the
talent the studios I'm sure they own
some buildings like like that adds up
I'm sure that just the Elder Scrolls
franchise was probably worth a couple
hundred million just that franchise
yeah yeah you know like uh you mean you
know uh yeah yeah I could definitely see
that probably more just awful the
strength of the IP like I think like
really the pricing of these uh
Acquisitions really comes down to do you
have IP or not in the IP that you do
have what is it worth
because if
Call of Duty wasn't in play with Apk
would it would it be as much as it is if
if
everything that King owns didn't grow
exponentially uh so recently would it
really be as much we look at what Sony
bought to get Insomniac what like 250
million that's an amazing AAA Studio but
what IP they have that I think that's
the point like the reason they are able
to Captivate so much on Insomniac is
because they didn't really buy IPS I I
think they already own Ratchet and Clank
so they they bought Sunset Overdrive
that's pretty much it
really awesome game didn't sell anything
so yeah it's not it's not worth a lot
you know so it makes total sense now
they're paying like 80 70 I can't
remember the amount billions for
Activision probably a good 10 of that's
just the Call of Duty franchise like I'm
sure they're paying a couple billion
dollars just for the Call of Duty
franchise
yeah is that so that's what it really
comes that's uh OverWatch
wow at League of Legends they don't own
them but wow OverWatch like OverWatch by
itself probably cost a couple hundred
Diablo a couple hundred million like
that's what that's why this studio
that's why this acquisition is so
expensive because Microsoft is
comfortable putting up more money as
long as they take those eyepiece home
with them
yeah because the the staff the you know
you hate to see them go if they did go
but you still have VIP that people look
for you could get more people in to work
on that game and whether the quality
shifts gets better or worse is is up in
the air but you what you have is the the
name you have Call of Duty the marketing
itself is probably worth hundreds of
millions of dollars oh absolutely yeah
absolutely absolutely uh um
uh what was it that Jim Ryan said in one
of those emails to someone else at Sony
um actually it wasn't your mind that was
the other person at Sony that said to
Jim Ryan that said like if they wanted
to just make Call of Duty exclusive they
could have spent five billion dollars
and made it exclusive for three or four
years all on their own all all on its
own and that's something that like I'm
sure thought of in that kind of money
yeah right right but you don't need to
spend that kind of money to make
Battlefield exclusive you don't need to
spend that kind of money to make other
another first person shooter exclusive
that's that's something that off the
strength of AIP or Call of Duty that you
would need to do if you if that's the
route that you wanted to go
um when it comes to other Publishers
they may acquire I just don't think
there's anyone out there left that like
they could realistically get not
necessarily realistically get in the
sense that they couldn't afford to but
could actually it's not about whether
they can afford it because we know they
can afford everybody under the sun if
they got ABK it's about getting through
the regulation process and having them
right yeah it have the other people sell
because this is very unique situations
for them for both Bethesda and and ABK
yeah so you could add a couple zeros on
to any deal it might you know who might
have them look at that deal again but at
the same time like when you get like one
thing you could say about Nintendo is
they're very passionate people they love
gaming that's why you know they they
what I've always felt like Nintendo
wants to make money but they make games
to make money they don't they they don't
I feel like a lot of companies
they get in here to to make money that's
all they care about but Nintendo I feel
like you know they didn't get it they
they're in the industry to make games
that so happens to make them money
and you know some of these other
companies they get into the game
industry because they see the amount of
money they can make
I think the creatives that Nintendo have
exactly that mindset that you have but I
think the business side of Nintendo is
this Cutthroat as possible yeah and I
think I think that stuff's gonna go on
sale they don't we ain't seen the switch
have a price drop since it released in
2017. that that thing is going to stay
where it's at I think there's a lot more
of
those people there's a lot more creative
people in executive positions in
Nintendo than the other ones too oh yeah
yeah okay yeah because I feel like you
could see a little back and forth over
there now obviously they're out to date
on a lot of stuff but I mean some of we
got to be real it they selling 10 plus
million zeldas and 150 million plus on
on on the switch
why do they gotta upgrade stuff like
that because clearly it's not affecting
their business
what if you look at Nintendo Hardware
they've always kind of designed the
hardware of their consoles based upon
what they were doing with their own
first party games and then hey look if
if you're a third party and you're fine
with that and you want to put your game
without our platform but cool hey you
know go ahead here's the license you
know go ham but they cared more like in
the look at their controller designs
look at just the the way they always
tend to go left when the rest of the
industry goes right them not caring
about online look if I think if if
they're if their Studios want it to go
in those directions that other people
are going more they would do that but I
think at this point the reason why
they're dropping the more powerful
Hardware now is because the games
they're going to be dropping out within
the next two or three years are going to
need more powerful Hardware to run
and that's why they're doing it and and
even then like there is rumors that the
new Switch isn't necessarily like on par
with the Xbox series consoles and the
PS5 they see this like we're looking at
last gen like they're they're on par
with last gen consoles probably maybe
the PS4 Pro and the Xbox or Xbox One X
kind of performance for it to be able to
like the rumor that it's it was running
Final Fantasy 7 remake and was playing
uh uh breath of the wild at 4K 60 but
you look at breath of the wild like I
mean sure any old Harwich that's vaguely
current should be able to run that at 4K
60. potato
midgen PCS running Yuzu emulator can run
breath of the wild at 4K 60. so yeah
they're they're they're increasing their
performance so that their first priority
can release release their games and to
the level of quality that they expect
from their their games but I don't think
it's uh it's them moving in a direction
of where the industry is going even
though I felt if they did do that they
could dominate I think
uh I think it would help and hurt them
it helped them always because they have
more power and and they can you know
hopefully get in front of like a
different audience but I think in order
to do that it would make them miss you
know price points you know uh a lot of
that would probably be
getting away from a handheld Market
because they would have to be stronger
and you it's harder to do that in a and
compact into a small machine for a
reasonable price so I think you know the
reason they're staying where they are is
because they feel comfortable there they
know that you know they
Tina Tammy uh Jake and whatever little
kid they know that that that parent
might buy all three of them a switch for
250 300 and not just all of them one
console so it I think that's the reason
they go that direction I think they
don't want to compete in the bigger
areas they they they like their little
they like being the big the big fish in
the small pond and I argue that they
care about third party but they don't at
the same time it could come and go for
all they care because guess what sure
they might not get GTA 6.
but when they dropped that new Mario or
that new Zelda GTA 6 also ain't
competing against Zelda
right but be the attic imagine right
imagine a switch to
that in handheld mode was like on par
with like the rock Ally
where you're getting like 720p 1080p
performance you're hitting like 45 to 60
FPS consistently no 30 FPS over here
you're running the most current games
and yeah your battery life ain't that
great but the switch battery life ain't
that great either so people are already
used to it but then when you go docked
mode that's when you get the increased
performance where you can play the same
games definitely not going to be at the
same like level of performance as a PS5
or Xbox series X but you can play the
same game
that everyone else is playing on those
other platforms here like I feel like if
they if they if they
would just care about that
I I think they would dominate but I
think the chief reason why they'll never
do that is Nintendo is all about making
a profit at launch
with Sony and Microsoft do when they
drop their new console at launch they're
losing money on every unit they either
well actually I think I think the
the series actually uh they made money
it was a couple dollars but I don't I
don't think they've lost money since
like the 360. because I know the Xbox
one it was a profit if I remember
correctly it wasn't a lot launch I had
launched
I remember in like the the court cases
there was a particular part where I
can't remember who was asked but they
were asked have has Xbox ever made a
profit off of the Xbox itself selling
the Xbox itself and the it was maybe it
was in this court case it may have been
the Epic uh Apple lawsuit where Xbox got
got roped into that and they had to uh
to speak on it but yeah they basically
was like you know we never made money
off of the console itself like selling
the console and so we've always taken a
little bit of a loss but where they make
their money is with the services with
the sale of games yeah yeah thank you I
think it was it was the Epic court case
where they were asked that explicitly
and they said no we we always take a
loss but that's something Nintendo's
never going to do Nintendo
Phil Spencer saying that
when they asked him that in an interview
I think with like Ryan McCaffrey or
something he said on there that they
make more money off of the consoles than
people think like I don't know yeah I
agree with that for some reason I'm I'm
getting conflicting things like I
remember that but I remember like the
Xbox one was making like 28 a box or
something like that like oh yeah but
maybe like later on in the when those
parts are so cheap and because it
because it's somewhat outdated at that
point let's say like three four years
into a console generation yeah
absolutely they're probably making a
little bit of money off of it per sale
of the box but
like at launch it launched you know like
that like I think PlayStation even on
the on the the more expensive one uh the
500 one wasn't making a profit until
like six months in on the PS5
and and they still were taking a loss on
the the the digital PS5 that was 400.
but I I don't I don't think they're
making a profit off of maybe the series
s is but I don't think the series X is
making a profit off of uh uh each each
individual sale of the system what I'll
do is I actually know someone that I can
actually answer that question yeah you
do that do that that's that's good some
good information to know yeah because
um you guys are most likely right I'm
not going to argue that but let's let's
move on with the show we we completely
went left right yeah I don't know what
we have lost the narrative man so let's
let's talk about this
um I'm sure a lot of you seen this
it is the we're going to be talking
about
the Bethesda leaked list which is is a
significantly like they they leaked but
cat yeah yeah I just heard it I was just
like this that sounds like a cat okay my
bad
here's here's the kid
what do you what's your problem
all right go cry somewhere else
um all right so let's talk about this we
got
we got
title release schedule it looks like
there is
a significant leap like did this yeah
this isn't a small like I I don't think
this is just Bethesda this isn't even
Xbox game studios this is just Bethesda
stuff and this
this looks like I feel like this is more
games in in development
already that PlayStation has like like
what this is that we know of absolutely
because we don't know exactly what
PlayStations putting out except for some
live service games that that they won't
even show gameplay for so yeah
absolutely this is way more than what
but but just Bethesda alone is way more
than what PlayStation is showing to this
to this what would you be fair when you
got like six seven Studios making stuff
I I I could expect that this boy you
would have a pretty good chance at you
know making a decent going out with this
all right so let's let's start at the
top
um you know obviously 2020 is like the
only year did Deadpool come out in 2020
no definitely came out in 2021 I think
so it looks like all these was pushed
back a year yes yeah except for when you
get further down they get pushed back
more than that but all right so let's
start uh Elder Scroll okay chat what I
want you to do is when I go over these I
want you to fact check these let's see
what years these came out all right I
want you to put it put it in the chat
all right so do maternal that was 2021
right
do maternal yes I don't no I think do
maternal was I think that's accurate
do maternal yeah it's going to March
20th 2020. all right so it made it's
it's deliverable okay the Elder Scrolls
Online graymore when did that come out
I'm I'm not even looking hold up Scrolls
graymore
that I didn't even heard of that I don't
even play Elder Scrolls Online that was
also 2020. all right so that made it uh
fallout wastelanders which is
interesting I think that's a shelter
thing in that fallout shelter thing
Fallout worlds
uh this that is is that an expansion or
is that the release of Fallout 76 that's
what I'm getting that's Fallout 76 yeah
because this guy wait no because fall 76
came out that that's what I'm saying
like yeah so maybe some expansion of the
Fallout 76 this is Fallout 76 has had
expansions all right so all right
yeah that's probably what that is when
did white Landers come out
damn all right uh
April 2020. okay so all the Death Loop
is 2021 right is it what's up with
definitely all right so they all made it
all right how do we get to the to the
craze which makes sense though because
the pandemic hit in 2020. so all the
stuff that like all the ones that came
out in 2020 they all came out in the
first half of 2020.
and then deaf Loop missed it and came
out in 2021 so you know at least you see
like how everything got pushed back
starting from there
all right makes a lot of sense so
Starfield was remember it was rumored
for the longest time Starfield was
coming out in 2021.
but we just kind of dismissed about two
years later yeah so that
slow mo
Bethesda was going to launch this sucker
in 2024. what were they going to launch
it probably would have been like a much
smaller game I get I I assume as far as
content goes like less factions
involved and less side quests and stuff
it had to be right redfall was going to
come out in 2021 too
I don't even what what game what game
was redfall in 2021
was it even a game
just
I don't know man I I can't I can't even
imagine what rarefall would have been if
they were released all right look look
up when ghost wire came out
see if that made it or was that 2022
that was because I got delayed a couple
times I remember
yeah that came out in 2020 through March
so it got pushed back a year
all right
um project hibika I think hi because I
don't know I don't care I believe that's
half I think that's high five rush I
think that's high yeah and that came out
this year yeah yeah uh Indiana Jones
supposed to come out 2022.
and they when did they even announce it
that wasn't even announced until like
chat tell me when that uh someone look
up on YouTube or Google uh the uh the
Indiana Jones announcement trailer tell
me what date that come in from
I'm kind of curious I think it was it
was a video game awards wasn't it
January 2021. no they just released it
they just like it was a random
like out of nowhere hey we're doing
an Indiana Jones game it was actually
very similar I think it was may have
been kind of push by lucasfilm games
because at the same time they also
within that same week of Indiana Jones
they also announced two Star Wars uh two
Star Wars games were coming out uh Star
Wars Outlaws was first uh being made by
said to be made by Massive entertainment
Ubisoft at that time so it was all that
stuff came out all at once it was kind
of pushed by by Disney and lucasfilm but
it wasn't an award show so people are
asking uh I saw when people are asking
on Twitter why is some of these games
being delayed two years and I have a I
have a theory on that so if you look at
the top
you know death Loop was delayed a year
because it was right at the beginning of
the pandemic uh so essentially it was
probably only delayed a couple months
um because they were further at the end
of the in the development they were
almost at the end of the development
Starfield was probably Midway if not
about to hit full production
uh and if people don't know food
production is if you was in if you were
in full production or was it close to
leaving full production by the time the
pandemic hit you were screwed
because there was no going to the office
it took most of these Studios months to
get back on track
is to some form
so that's probably what happened to
Starfield look I'm not going to give
them the excuse when it comes to redfall
I think redfall was doomed from the
start because you had a bunch of people
that didn't really understand what they
wanted to do I think it it's been
canceled yeah it should have been
canceled but the Doom Eternal DLC that
was the Battle of the Gods when did that
come out
did that make it because it's DLC one
would think that that probably could
have made that
Eternal it was called Battle of the Gods
yeah Battle of the Gods or something
like that
foreign
March 18th of
why am I just getting someone said yeah
2021 2021 yeah so he did make it so uh
clearly
um
newer IPS take longer and and full
production so that's probably why you
know um
Hi-Fi Rush took so long
yeah yeah in this yeah a new IP you're
you're starting off
um completely brand new you're breaking
new ground you need you need you're
making new assets no it's it's called
the ancient gods that's what it's called
It's called The Angels probably the
reason why it was hard for me to find it
I think I think I just told you a Dragon
Ball Z uh name
but not like like new IPS they you're
creating new assets you're creating new
game designs there's a lot of new things
there they take longer to develop in
addition to if you're even if you're
using an existing game engine you're
going to be creating new tools to kind
of adapt that engine to what you need it
for for this particular IP so yeah that
stuff's gonna take much longer and then
you know of course you get sequels where
you're reusing the assets and then you
reuse those assets and the the the
actual development period is shorter
yeah so then then we get down here to
Indiana Jones you know
like I said new IP I'm pretty sure that
by the time like people don't realize
but when it comes to the pandemic
that's why when people talk about the
pandemic and they say it's you can't use
that as an excuse for poor uh for
development being extended I just if you
can't use a world pandemic
what isn't that what what's an
acceptable excuse at that point
like people are like oh well you know
Sony had no problem with it yeah because
Sony had a lot more games that was
farther in development hey aslamo what
what's the last game notice that their
production has almost halted at this
point
because the games that they ain't
showing us is the games that was being
made during the pandemic
that's true that is true and I think
there's some studios that are the reason
why the pandemic is so uh disruptive is
that there are Studios that were kind of
already made for something like that you
look at like Moon Studios which is like
a entirely remote like like remote
Studio like they are less impacted by
this than say other Studios and most AAA
they're not capable of working from home
like that a couple of departments couple
people from coupled Apartments yeah but
not to this degree I was I was told that
it like
are you okay
the cat like jumped on something and it
fell on them
okay keep talking
but no yeah to to to that kind of
thought like I I actually talked to a
Ubisoft developer recently because uh I
I when back during June when Ubisoft had
their showcase I I didn't understand how
massive entertainment was making two AAA
games at the same time like it didn't
make sense to me how are they making
Star Wars Outlaws and also making Avatar
at the same time like how are they able
to do that and
the the guy he used to work for Ubisoft
but he said like Ubisoft has a a whole
cloud-based database infrastructure and
code code environment where they're able
to uh produce updates to A Game's build
in in real time without having to take
the whole build off lots of other people
can't update it and they even though a
lot of people talk you know ish about
Ubisoft and their game design but as far
as like their tools and how they work
behind the scenes they're very very
forward forward thinking and and
basically they were not as impacted as
hard with the pandemic as other Studios
were because they were already kind of
building an infrastructure that allowed
them to be able to to work like this so
like meanwhile plus they got like five
to six Studios working on every game you
got a studio in America that sleep and
there's a studio out in Budapest that's
working on the same game continuing to
keep that game going and that's how
they're able to like make so much
content and have all that stuff come out
but
there's some studios and Publishers that
are set up for that and there's some
that just absolutely weren't and the
majority absolutely were not set up for
they've yeah they've never had a
situation it's like I said sure maybe
some of them work from home but not not
to this degree not everyone is working
from home and I was told that there were
some studios that just didn't work for
three four months and three or four
months you got to consider coming back
after a three or four months hiatus it's
probably going to take a month just to
get back on track to even remotely get
back on track and if you if you were
working on mocap that's a wrap
there was no mo capping being done at
that time
because you need multiple people in the
studio to do that you know I was told I
was told um Ninja Theory was out for
like five months
they were doing little bits of things
but they they weren't really doing very
well at the beginning obviously people
started getting uh handling I think you
started seeing a lot of healing going on
when the
when the the
when the shot came out because I felt
like that gave people a little
reassurance a little bit where okay you
know we can legally be back in the same
room now
all right so let's let's move on
Oblivion remaster
That was supposed to come out last year
it's not coming out of here either it's
a rematch well I guess how much of a
remaster is this because there's some
remastes where it's just like
it's it's it's it's very ho-hum it's
just like oh okay I mean they they
cleaned up a few testers here and there
it's not that big a deal it it still
looks dated and then there's some other
remastes you're like wow like that that
looks a that looks amazing they
what do they do with it to make it look
that good so maybe it's the latter and
that's why it's still not out yet
yeah but do you also know this here so
the way they originally had it Starfield
was supposed to come out in 2021 and
then and then the Starfield DLC was
supposed to come out a year later I
wonder if that's still the Cadence that
we're going to get we'll probably get a
DLC six months
yeah that would make sense so we'll
still be out next year that would make
sense to me yeah here's a an interesting
term of events Doom year zero
and DLC
what the hell does that mean you know I
I was told by like people I had a new
game
apparently it's a prequel
maybe how Doom Slayer became the person
he is I don't know
but interesting I'm curious how that
happened because I was told that they
were working on something else that they
were done with Doom after the gods DLC
uh so maybe maybe that's a smaller title
and we just don't know it
uh maybe I was told [__] information
and they're working I would prefer them
to work on Doom over Quake because I
feel like Doom is an easier sell than
quake
yeah I agree with that yeah project
kestra I have no clue what that is
I have no idea history that is either
yeah
I don't see the xenomax media new MMO
game on this list could that be it
and see if you look down it says
expansion in 2024 so that's got to be
denim Max's new game but they said
multiple times that xenomax's new game
was supposed to be ip'd didn't they like
some form of IP I remember there's
rumors that is Mandalorian and
like a license game it's a licensed game
so that kind of makes me think that's
what the license game in 2024 is
I I had this theory about it and and
there's nothing to this Theory it's just
the theory I had but you know Cinemax
media has made live service uh
uh Elder Scrolls Online MMO we got
Fallout 76 which is their multiplayer
version of Fallout what if they had a
multiplayer version of Starfield
and that ends up being what project
Kestrel is
I mean I think that would actually be
pretty
pretty awesome considering how the
universe is
yeah really that that too yeah but I
kind of have that like in simultaneous
development along with Starfield the
single player experience I think I think
that'd be pretty cool and if it comes
out next year you can kind of capitalize
on some of the excitement of Starfield
and get some of the people who may who
may have just stopped playing the game
or still playing it to jump in there too
but all right what about this license IP
game go and uh talk about that why I I I
I'm a I'm a I'm gonna handle the kids
I'll be right back okay so the license
IP game I'm thinking has to be a Disney
property they had already negotiated a a
deal with lucasfilm games for Indiana
Jones it wouldn't surprise me at all if
you you built upon that that
relationship there by deciding to hey do
another license IP who knows it could be
something Marvel related it could be
something which I think if you're gonna
go in that direction
uh if you're gonna go in that direction
then I would say
I would say
The Punisher
being made by machine games is the route
that I would like to go
but that's uh that's that's just me
that's just me but I I do think it has
to be something Disney related that
Disney would be involved with this
license IP is uh since they already have
been working with them with Indiana
Jones
I feel like
once if it's a Starfield game because
not Starfield uh Star Wars game because
I feel like they're doing a lot of Star
Wars these days
yeah
if it is Star Wars would you what do you
think it is
the difference who's making it I I don't
think xenomax is making it because
they're making something else
I don't know let's see here I love that
I see license IP because I've always
been a contender that saved Microsoft
and Xbox need to be more open with their
bank account when it comes to having
license IP developed like I understand
people say well it's because they can't
control that that's fine but you need to
make sure that your brand is being
talked about in other forms of media and
not just your and not just the gaming
media
like for instance Edge Runners I could
not describe to you how much I gave up
on cyberpunk I didn't care about it it's
like it's over Edge Runners has got me
back where I'm considering playing and
yeah great it's a great series like that
that was so good it was so good that I'm
thinking maybe Microsoft Nintendo and
Sony need to invest in the studios that
make [__] because it like look they
don't got they don't gotta distribute it
you know they don't got to do that like
Microsoft
Nintendo they they can they can found
Studios and go let other people fund the
the games the the the shows you know
what I'm saying but Microsoft
Sony
and Nintendo need
their people need to actually make it
yeah if I could recall correctly but
Edge Runners came out on Netflix the
sales of cyberpunk increased like 300 or
something like that something ridiculous
like it was like crazy ridiculous
percentage that it went up and I I
play cyberpunk at launch and although I
enjoyed it I didn't enjoy it to the
degree that I thought I could have
because of all the bugs and issues and
it was really annoying and by the time I
got to finishing it I would I
uninstalled it with the quickness
now
once Edge Runners came out now watch
that started looking at like all the
different weapons they were using I'm
like oh that oh that's in the game
and and then like the same device that I
never used the same division in the game
yes everything that you saw in Edge
Runners is in this the game including
the Ripper doc that was working on David
Gonzalez he's you can go to that Ripper
dock in the game and see him all those
weapons the shotgun the leader of their
their group had that he was using I
think it's called The Crusher that
shotgun's in the game the mono wire that
the girl had yeah I saw a gameplay from
that that uh Lucy used to the yes all
that stuff when I realized that I was
like I gotta do another playthrough and
when I did when I man when I did that
second play through
it was it was just it was Bliss it was
so good and I I took all I made the edge
Runners build where I used everything I
used the same division combined with the
mono wire so I would activate slow
everything down and just literally
ripped people apart it was it was epic I
I've been told by I don't know if it's
true or not because I don't look into
stuff like this but that there's
supposed to be missions and the new
expansion that like kind of relate to
Edge runners in a way
um
like and maybe because they are there
there do things happen in the show that
some of them would be uh but let's let's
move on let's move on all right so uh
Dishonored three I'm gonna be real with
you that was the only game on this list
that there's been no leaks
there's been nothing
yeah
yeah and this this has to be uh Arcane
Leon working on it you know because we
know how you know the the reporting came
out for Austin and what they have been
working on how big the team was so first
for Dishonored 3 to be in development
this has to be just the the the the that
Leon team and they probably really
jumped in on it once death Loop was
finished
yes it works
I feel them on a man so
let me ask you this
um
first off I want I want your opinion
on as long as first off like Dishonored
three we know Dishonored one and two
were good games it's just they didn't oh
two then so uh the greatest uh we know
that a lot of the studios that are under
bethesdaq they do produce quality work
um uh you know we we see stuff like
Fable even Halo to a point because I
feel like they they're slowly bringing
that game back to where it should have
been at launch
and you know we're seeing all this good
movement with Microsoft do you think
between
bethesda's lineup and Xbox's lineup That
their
their notorious history where they go
six months to a year and don't really
announce anything don't really release
anything do you think that's pretty much
gone as long as these games do what
they're supposed to
I I think we'll probably end up in
somewhere in a happy medium I don't
think they'll ever achieve this in like
every three months or every or every
quarter they release a first party game
I don't think that's
when you look at the nature of game
development and how you you'll get games
that get delayed you'll get games that
that you know some certain things become
unforeseen that you can't handle and you
the best choice instead of releasing
something that isn't Readiness
incomplete really is to delay the game
today it's for the betterment of the
game and the betterment of it of its uh
reception to The Gaming Community I
think that
well we're going to get those periods
every now and then it will be six months
of no content because just something
unforeseen happen but I don't think
we'll ever get 2022 again where the only
first party release was uh pentiment
a small a much much smaller focused game
good game but much much smaller Focus I
don't think we'll see that again with
the number of Studios they have with
them now a lot of them being into
full-on development or and have adjusted
to this new way of doing game
development where you know you're gonna
have either be
hybrid remote or a lot of people just
full-on remote in order to make sure
that you're consistently working on your
your game development and getting those
games ready for launch I I think that
more than likely every now and then
we'll get those releases where it's like
hey it's a game released in February and
then the next one doesn't release until
August but I don't think it will be just
one game
for a full year and it's not even a
triple A game you know like I think
we saw that email that actually came out
with Phil Spencer was really kind of
like if you really re if you ever had a
a director director team on on
issues where they need to be better
you can kind of read between the lines
of that email of like yo this is
unacceptable just straight up this is
unacceptable we don't have any content
we're not dropping any content right now
we have to fix this and this this needs
to never happen again and you look at
the names that are cc'd
um and and put you know to he addressed
this to it's all their leadership
yeah so I I think they they will fix the
content release schedule even so much as
hey not to make sure they don't have two
games releasing on top of each other hey
you we're gonna release you three months
later this gives you more time to polish
your game and you know get all the Kinks
wrinkled out you know out and everything
and make sure you're ready to go but we
need to do this so that we have
consistent content and not just a flush
of a bunch of content all at once and
then a drought so I think doing things
like that which I believe was actually
even mentioned by Phil Spencer
um and either that email or a different
one I think those are things they're
going to start deploying to make sure
that there are no more 2022s but there's
definitely going to be I just don't
think we'll ever get that Zen like every
three months
bang is a new release bang there's a new
release I just don't think that's
reality yeah I agree
I just I I think you know you clearly
see that this dilemma and this thing
that people like to say that Microsoft
isn't doing these Studios any good
they're not like really investing into
them they gave Starfield and redfall and
Indiana Jones like a year and a half to
two years of extra funding that's a lot
of money
mm-hmm
um
a lot of other Studios would have just
put it out because you see it all the
time we'll put this half ass game out
that barely functions because most the
time they're like they rather see some
money than none
yeah uh but Microsoft didn't do that
they're like look like we gotta we gotta
do this right so let's let's delay
Starfield two years let's delay the um
Indiana Jones well almost three
so it's just like a lot of people
wouldn't get that now obviously if these
games come out and they're not
successful then I would start to see
some head rolls but Microsoft owns these
Studios I don't think you'll see them
being closed down I think you'll see the
leadership change
if stuff like that would happen I don't
think they would just shut them down I
think either they would they would
leadership change or they would convert
them into support Studios
right a support Studio under uh some
other other main Studio I think that
would definitely be the end result of
hey look we
closing a studio down it
it's it's kind of it it sucks right but
it's also it is a reality of the gaming
industry overall if you think about it
like it's
especially when the when game
development AAA game development is
becoming more and more expensive like we
got game it used to be a AAA game was
like 50 75 million dollars now it's like
150 to 200 million dollars is what a
triple A game costs and
if if your game fails like that's hard
to justify how to keep that studio open
if you don't think that like you can
actually get that level of content of a
game out and actually it'd be profitable
and the kind of loss that you have to
take in order to absorb yeah you're
either gonna end up being a support
Studio
or they're going to get rid of you that
they do think Microsoft probably go to
the the supports to the route because
they need more of those someone said
rainfall still came out half-assed it
did but what did it look like before it
got the year and a half delay
probably way worse then he said
Microsoft shut down lion head Studios
and they never made a bad game they made
Fable three
and that's debatable if it's like a bad
game or not but you know I think that
was at a time where Microsoft didn't
know what they were wanting to do with
the the uh the company and I think that
it was like a 50 50 if they're gonna
keep it or not there might have actually
been a time where they were going to
shut down the Xbox Division and maybe
that's the reason some of these
decisions were made it's like look if
you want to keep it around we got to cut
the budgeting so we got to cut some of
these teams
and I think that's when you've seen that
I would actually like and I know they
would never do this to replace plague or
uh to replace uh playground games his
second team and rename it to lion head
Studio
because I I actually feel like that name
go like goes with Fable at this point
but yeah pretty much I mean they created
that second team
to do Fable so I mean I could that could
make a lot of sense if they decide to go
that route yes um
I'll go ahead go ahead so uh anything
else you want to say on this I think
we'll go ahead and head out of here
almost two hours man
no no I think I think uh I think that's
all really I mean I think those are like
crying really to me the most important
things uh from that came out from the
leak is the games like that's what I
care about the most though yeah because
because the cost was like we knew that
[__] was coming
everyone knew that was coming including
PlayStation sure maybe PlayStation knows
a little bit more info than they should
but they knew it was coming like so
anyway tell the people where to find
gsolo
yo slow mo back slap is the name um
channel is the same name uh
um I I do a lot of content I do TPS card
DPS podcast damage per second Podcast
Thursday nights tomorrow on 9pm Eastern
Standard time we have our own channel
for that me and gaming Forte and if you
uh you want to come by and hang out with
us could please do so I've also been
doing a lot of content on let's see
telltale's the expanse the first
descendant which uh a live streamed
yesterday I'll be live streaming
tomorrow we're dropping the video and
some uh some tips and some things for
people playing the game to to you know
check out and you know help them out and
you know that's that's about it you know
slow backslab everywhere Twitter
tick tock
twitch same name all that stuff
so
um yeah I appreciate the invite as usual
yeah I think we're gonna go over here to
uh to fame uh we're gonna raid them and
we pop let me pop them up on the screen
here so here's Fame
I will be looking at this uh you know
he's got 21 people now let's get that
over to like 70 to 80 man let's get over
there Fame uh Fang's a good dude I think
he would really appreciate it being a
dude so uh guys go over there show them
some love you know twit uh go over there
IOP raid addict show raid whatever you
guys want to do I don't care but
appreciate for coming through we had up
to like almost 400 people in the chat
hit that like on your way to fame's
podcast and until next week uh you know
once again apologize darts on here I
know this is a really big week uh but
family comes first man family comes
first but appreciate everybody through
here and we'll talk to you later